Hello!
Hey, Dad's here!
Let me turn on the lo-fi for us.
Let's see...
Whoa!
It's a little too loud for me.
Might not be loud enough for you guys.
Today I feel a little bit... a little comfy today.
Let's see... oh, maybe it is loud for you guys.
Let me double check.
Ooh, okay, let me turn that down a little bit.
Alright.
That should be better.
Alright!
Hello!
Why am I short?
Because I want Dad to be here for a little bit.
Um... that's why I'm short.
I just want Dad to be here for a little bit before I kick him away.
Alright, goodbye, Dad.
Apparently...
Apparently the dragoons didn't want you here!
Bye!
That's what THEY wanted!
No!
I was wrong!
Oh, you want him back?
It's too late.
I kicked him out.
It's too late, dragoons!
You missed... you missed the thing.
You didn't know you missed the thing that you wanted the most.
One guy!
Alright, I was hydrating.
I ordered my new headphones today.
Um, it's gonna be arriving tomorrow.
Uh, I'm feeling a little... I'm feeling very comfy today.
Um, at least just because I'm like really tired, uh, in general.
I think like, uh...
Usually, uh, whenever, uh...
When I'm like in a mindset where I'm like, ooh, the day is over.
My mind just goes straight into like, it's time.
It's almost time to hibernate.
And I'm like, oh, thank God.
And I'm like, I forgot.
No, I didn't forget!
Uh, but like, I think like I subconsciously...
Um, subconsciously was like preparing in advance.
Uh, to like, uh, be in like, relax, chill mode.
And, uh, and I'm just like, I'm ready to...
I'm ready for my two rest days, definitely.
I think like this week has been...
This week has definitely been a lot.
This week, uh, a lot of stuff has been going on behind the scenes.
Um, and there's like a lot of things to do.
I think like lately this week, I've been definitely sleeping more.
Because I've been feeling a lot more mentally tired from a lot of work.
Uh, that's been going on behind the scenes.
Um, I'm so sorry.
Uh, I was getting a lot of like, uh, people asking about the whitelist.
We've stopped whitelisting for the last two days.
Because we thought that we would have the server up by now.
Um, so like we were just preparing.
We were just preparing the Minecraft servers.
I'm so sorry for those who are still waiting to be whitelisted.
Um, if by tomorrow we have...
We did not set up...
If by tomorrow we haven't set up the server yet, we're gonna be posting a new way to...
Uh, like a Google form.
If we don't have the server up, we'll be doing like a Google form.
Um, for it.
But we'll see.
There's just so many things going on.
Also, form, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm really sorry for those who are still waiting.
Um, we are still...
There was like a lot of stuff going on.
Uh, behind the scenes at the moment.
But we have stopped whitelisting, I think like two days ago.
Uh, so you haven't been whitelisted yet.
And you're still waiting on it.
Um, you might have to wait a little bit longer.
Because we are currently going through some little things in the behind the scenes regarding setting up the Discord server for it.
So I really appreciate your patience, everybody.
Um, and yes, I know I haven't uploaded the new outfit.
The, the, the skin to reveal stuff.
Oh.
That's why I'm looking forward to...
Um, I'm really looking forward to, uh, the next two rest days.
Because I'm pretty sure I'm like...
Right now, I feel like really tired.
Yeah, there's a lot, lot going on at the moment.
So, um, that's why I've been like...
I've been like super, I guess like more tired than usual.
Uh, for this week.
Because I think this week has been a lot that's been going on.
Um, in the backlog for behind the scenes.
So, uh, definitely gonna be using, uh, the two rest days to just like catch up on stuff.
As well as, uh, cause like, I know it doesn't seem like it.
Because I do still keep my stream consistent.
Um, so like I try to, I still try to like stream consistently.
Even though I know like there's a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes.
Um, I don't wanna sacrifice, I don't, I try not to sacrifice, uh, my stream time.
With you guys, um, and everything.
Um, so, uh, like, like on stream, I feel like I got my shit together.
But after...
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Off stream Doki is a different...
Hahahaha Is a different circumstance.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Um...
Um...
Yeah, um...
So, uh, I'm really looking forward to the two rest days.
Uh, but I'm glad to just, you know, end the week.
Uh, end the week, uh, to...
With a good night, Dragoons.
Just to like hang out with all of you guys.
We're like much more comfy, much more relaxed today.
Uh, so I'm just, I just like talking with you guys.
You know, just giving you guys little updates and stuff.
And like just doing little satsudon.
And everything.
Um, Eric, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, today was definitely a day.
Had to run back and forth all over town.
Not fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
It's been a, uh, busy week.
Get some rest.
You deserve it too.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Nexy.
I really, really, really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Um, but yes.
Um, if...
Though, if I do feel tired after the second rest day.
I might take a third rest day in a row.
Just to make sure that...
Because I can feel my brain...
I can feel my brain being very slow.
Like, I could...
I could definitely, like, feel, like, the cogs in my brain turning really, really slow at the moment.
So I definitely need to rest.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, do you know what, like, what I've, uh...
What I've, like, noticed though?
Um...
What I've noticed, like, uh...
Recently in the...
In the...
Recently in the coming...
Like, not...
Sorry, I can't word right now.
Like I said, my brain has been, like, really, really slow, um, the last couple of days.
Um, but, like, what I've noticed, uh, the last couple of months was that I've been, like, super unfiltered.
I...
I literally...
I literally called Pikachu a fat fuck.
I was like, oh my god, I would have never called him that in the past.
I would have been like, he's a chunky little boy.
But I was like, no, he's a fat fuck.
But, like, old...
Like, old Pikachu design.
I... I realized, like, past Doki would have just been like, oh, he's a chunky little boy.
But now I'm like, fat fuck!
And I spoke with, like...
I spoke with so much passion for that.
Um...
I realized I've been, like, so unfiltered the last couple of months because, like, I guess, like, you know, when you're in indie, um, I don't have to worry about being, like, super careful about what I'm saying.
And, like, being, like, I guess, like, making sure I don't, like, I guess...
Oh, what's the word?
Uh, making sure that...
You know, I don't say...
I made sure that I don't say anything that would, like, offend people too much.
Because I have been, like...
In the past, I'd be like, oh, no.
What would Nintendo think if I called their main Pokemon mascot, their main goddamn mascot, a fat fuck?
Well, like, back then, you know, during the 1990s, his original design.
Um...
Like, spon...
Sponsored...
Sponsored-friendly.
Um...
But, honestly, like, I realized, you know, ever since, like, becoming in indie, um...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, Pikachu lost a lot of weight.
No, I...
No, he did.
The reason why I said that was because I was like, oh, yeah, guys.
Pikachu used to be, like, this chunky, now, look at him.
Now, like, every...
Every ten years, he gets skinnier and skinnier, and it's just, like...
Like...
Every every every ten years they keep making him skinnier.
Oh, I was looking up like I was actually looking up like old Pikachu designs.
I was so okay.
I was like, oh my god.
They they actually did they just like they just made him like like oh, sorry Well, he's back.
I forgot to...
That's gonna pop in and out.
I love I think this is my favorite.
Okay.
I realized I binded I binded dad to the wrong... I binded dad to the wrong place.
So you're gonna see him again really soon like right now.
And he's gonna be gone in three two one
Anyway, I was like looking at like old Pikachu designs and I love somebody made this comparison
I love like the progression of like I love it was like 1995 and then like what the fuck happened?
2018 he turned into Minecraft Pikachu turned into Minecraft.
No, it's I don't know if you guys remember this but this was 2018 was there Was Nintendo's mobile games phase where they made like yeah, it was like blockachu and then like...
They made a...
Well, not Minecraft, but like what's the word?
They made like a like a block version of of Pokemon For like an iPhone game for like an iPhone because there's also an Android before like a phone game the mo Yeah, they had a mobile game Nintendo had a mobile game phase were Were like...
They made a bunch of Nintendo games on the phone because it was the next big thing.
So one of them was like, what if Pokemon were blocks that were shaped like Minecraft?
And also we can merchandise that and make them into off-brand Lego blocks for Pokemon.
And also made them into plushie form too.
The thing about Nintendo is that games are not what makes them money now.
It is merchandising.
Not just Nintendo, but like Pokemon.
Pokemon's biggest income is not video games.
Because they know people buy whatever fucking Pokemon game comes out.
It doesn't matter.
Don't lie to me.
Whatever they make, you guys will buy it.
You see, I broke out of that programming.
I haven't bought a Poke... okay, JK, never mind.
I bought Legends of Arceus because they actually tried a new formula.
But other than that, Legends of Arceus is like their actual... they went out of formula.
But other than that, I didn't buy any other Pokemon game.
I still buy their merch because like I've broken their video game programming.
But I haven't broken their merch programming.
I still buy Pokemon merch.
Because Pokemon...
Pokemon is less of a game company and more of a merchandise company now.
So that's why like everything they do is incredibly calculated in a way that like what makes the most...
What kind of merchandise would make the most... like what kind of design, what kind of product would make the most money.
Like that Pokemon sleep app they did.
They fucking instantly made merchandise off of it.
Like...
They instantly made like the... what was it?
The sleeping Pokemon merch out of the app that they did.
And people bought that shit.
People as in me.
I bought a sleeping Pokemon plushie.
And also Pokemon cards.
To be fair, I realized like Pokemon cards, they actually make it much more...
What's the word?
They make it much more... less scal...
They try to make it as less scalpable as possible.
Because I know like they like limit people on Pokemon card sales so that kids can actually own the cards as well.
So they made it more affordable for... and actually more...
Like harder to scalp compared to like other stuff they do.
Because like...
You know, they don't want to...
They try to make sure that it's affordable.
Like you know, it's still a company for children.
Like to appeal to the kids.
So they still want the kids to be able to afford it.
And to be able to experience it.
So that's something that they're really good at doing.
Yeah, you can't buy...
No, you can.
I'm pretty sure you can buy boosters.
Or I guess not like whole box of boosters.
You're just limited.
You're limited to like an amount of packs you can buy.
Brainwash them early?
Yeah, I mean...
Other companies do that.
Why do you think like fast food restaurants started to do like play areas?
Like...
It's not a new thing.
Why do you think like there's play areas in fast food...
In fast food places?
It was to make sure like the children were there.
And like...
And then like toys too.
Like the...
The fast food toys that you get.
I used to...
Remember the ones?
The Burger King ones with the...
With the...
The gold Pokemon cards.
And then there were like...
You know, that's where how I got introduced to Neopets.
Because of the...
Because of the toys that they were handing out in like fast food.
But that's what...
That's basically...
It works.
Ew.
You think Ronald McDonald was made for adults?
Like...
It works.
Anyway, what was I gonna say?
Oh my gosh, I don't know why...
I don't know how I got into the...
Oh yeah, yeah.
The reason why...
I got into...
I got into this tangent...
Was that...
It definitely feels nicer...
To be able to...
Like...
You know...
Be able to criticize things.
And...
That was like the whole point of the tangent.
That I can actually like criticize stuff when needed.
And like call out things.
Being able to call things out.
And form opinions on stuff.
Because it's like...
You know...
I feel like...
What's so weird?
I keep thinking like what's so weird?
Because I'm trying to like formulate a better way to explain this.
I think it's very healthy to be able to criticize stuff.
Because like...
If you're...
If you don't have any opinions...
If you're always trying to like...
Be as PG as possible...
Then I think that's boring.
I think that's really...
Boring of a content creator.
Because like...
You know...
The fun thing is always...
You can also like get to banter with your chat.
About different opinions you have.
About like...
Like you know...
Because I called like Paramount ugly.
And then you guys were like...
No he's not.
And I'm like...
Yeah he is.
He's literally a thumb with wings.
And...
Being able to like banter with you guys.
About like...
About stuff.
And like seeing like different opinions on things.
And...
But...
Paramount ugly is such a strange take though.
Because he is ugly.
I don't understand.
He's just like a fucking blob.
He's like a potato.
And the eyes aren't even cute as all...
At all.
Please don't make me go back into the tangent of how ugly Paramount is.
It's not just...
Okay.
It's not the fact that he has simple design.
There's simple designs that work really well.
But Paramount...
Paramount is not one of them.
It's literally a potato.
It's a giant fucking orange potato.
With like a bat wing stuck on it's head.
It's not...
The eyes aren't even cute at all.
The eyes are like...
Like what's wrong with their eyes?
We got our own opinion.
Anyway...
Yeah but Mama Shiba...
Mama Shiba is different.
Mama Shiba at least...
It's a dog.
It's like a dog peanut.
That's different.
Dog beans are different because it's part dog.
And anything that's part dog is good.
You're wrong and that's okay.
And they say fun facts chat.
They...
Mama Shiba...
Mama Shiba gives you fun exciting facts that expand your brain.
Okay sorry.
I got...
I can get...
I get way too passionate about this.
Simpson thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was like I was gonna say.
But you know it's nice to be able to...
I guess like...
Speak freely on stuff.
Like you know if I don't like something I can be like yeah that sucked.
Like...
Yeah I could be like yeah that...
That was...
I could be like yeah I didn't have great time playing...
Doing this part of the game.
Or like yeah this is a poor...
Or this is like you know this is garbage.
Like...
This could have been improved on.
So it's nice to be able to...
Um...
Be able to criticize and be able to form opinions.
And like...
Um...
You know be...
Be able to express my thoughts.
And I realized like lately I've been like super unfiltered.
Lately.
It's usually in the past I have like filtered myself a lot.
Like I have filtered myself a lot in the past.
And I try I always like think about what I'm...
People think that I actually don't think about what I'm saying in the past.
But I actually did.
Um...
I actually try to make sure.
Like I don't say anything.
That was like sort of like a brand risk.
And be like less opinionated on stuff.
Because like when you're part of...
When you're a content creator.
Um...
When...
Uh...
You're...
Well of course I have to still be careful.
Of course.
Because like I still want a career.
Um...
I still...
I still want a career.
But I've definitely like...
Definitely loosened it up.
I've loosened up like what I say.
And like what I say to you guys.
And like what my thoughts are on things.
And...
But like definitely in the past I have like restricted myself a lot.
To keep like a lot of my thoughts to myself.
When it comes to like oh if I didn't like something I wouldn't say it.
I'd just be like oh yeah like if they can approve this.
They should do this instead.
Like um...
I did...
They'll be like yeah I did have a good time.
And the inside will be like I didn't have a good time.
But I can't say this game is garbage.
I can't really say this game that's made by a big company was dog shit.
But...
But I'll power through it.
I would insinuate and not say it directly.
Um...
Doc thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Dad deserves a good night.
Can we have him back?
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Alright.
Here's dad for like two seconds.
Say hello to dad for like two seconds.
One...
Two...
Goodbye dad.
Woo!
It was definitely a video game.
But it's nice.
It's nice.
I still try to make sure, you know, I do try to be very careful when it comes to like stuff I say.
Because, you know, I'm still a content creator.
And as a content creator, you have like, you know, an image to like, you have an image to keep clean.
And you do have to be careful with stuff you can and can't say.
And I'm just here to make you guys have fun and laugh, basically.
I'm just, I just want to like turn off my brain and just hang out and hang out with my dragoons and just, you know, have fun, laugh and everything.
Um, let's see what else.
Thank you for that one gift and share.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
You know, like when we were playing, when we were playing Digimon World, I remembered.
I remember.
There was like one game I was like, oh my God.
I really want to play Monster Rancher.
I actually, I used to play.
I used to play a lot of Monster Rancher growing up.
But then like my dad also bought the Japanese copy of that.
So I also did not know what I was doing.
There's like a habit of that where it was like Monster Rancher 2.
I think it was Monster Rancher 2 on the PlayStation 1.
Was it 2?
It had to be 2.
But because I know I saw Monster Rancher 1 and it looked the graphics on that looked like worse than Monster Rancher 2.
I need to make sure.
I think it was 2.
Yeah.
Also, I love the anime too.
Monster Rancher.
Um, but I remember my dad bought me or I don't know if he bought it for himself.
I couldn't.
I can't tell.
I think he bought it for himself because a lot of the games that I played in the PS1 was like, it was just my dad's hand-me-downs.
So I'm pretty sure.
Anyway, Monster Rancher.
For those who don't know what Monster Rancher was, it was basically like Digimon World.
But like the monsters weren't digital.
And they could also talk.
So like they weren't Pokemon because like the monsters in Monster Rancher actually die.
They didn't like fake die.
They like die die and they can talk to you.
They didn't have hot monsters in Monster Ranchers.
So there was no rent.
So I'm sorry guys, but there was no angel woman or like Angelmon in Monster Rancher.
They were actually monsters.
So I think that's why it wasn't as popular as Digimon because they didn't have like they didn't have the Digimon.
Yeah.
What's the point?
It didn't have the Digimon turn into like hot monsters.
Hot, I guess like angels.
So it wasn't as popular as Digimon.
But...
Hahahaha.
So...
Um...
So like...
It was...
It's just like...
It's just a farm for monsters.
And you like raise them and like you fight...
Use them to fight other monsters and everything.
But yeah, I used to...
You train them, you raise them, they can die.
Um...
But I remember playing Monster Rancher 2.
As a little bird.
And um...
I didn't know what's going on because my dad was had the Japanese copy of it.
Um...
So like I had no idea what's going on.
So I was just pressing random buttons.
But I always love seeing the monsters running around the track and like going into the barn to sleep.
That's all I could remember.
I...
Hahahaha.
That's literally all I can remember from um...
From the game.
But I had a good time.
I had a good time.
Um...
Let's see...
Uh...
DarkBlade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki and Dragoons.
I'm at a restaurant called...
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm at a restaurant called...
You should get a... burger.
I had a pasta last night.
So, I don't want you to eat the same thing as I did.
So you're gonna eat a burger.
Pasta night is my pasta night.
Not your pasta night.
So you should get a burger.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you saying you aren't into any monsters?
Seriously, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's a wild question to ask me.
And unlike goodnight dragoons, like...
That's an incredibly wild question to ask me on a supposedly chill lo-fi relaxing stream.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm gonna give that answer for just 10 dollars.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
What was I gonna talk about?
I should have a list of topics that I wrote down.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
This is gonna get a little like mushy here.
But like...
I also like...
Um...
I also...
Definitely needed the...
To...
The rest day.
Uh...
To...
To rest...
Okay.
This is gonna get a little like...
I'm opening up myself a little bit, guys.
So it's gonna get a little mushy here.
Uh...
So I'm gonna like open myself a little bit.
Like open myself up a little bit.
Um...
Oh well, money is the issue.
Okay.
Haha!
Yes!
I...
Read it in!
And then next thing...
Thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you.
Oh well.
Money is the issue.
Hahaha!
Haha!
Thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you!
Thanks!
See?
Hahaha!
Um...
Alright.
Before we...
Get on to that.
Um...
Uh...
The only other reason why...
I definitely need to take more rest days...
I had to take a back-to-back rest day.
Was that...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Haha!
Alright.
This is why like...
Okay.
I told my mods.
Because I was like...
My mo- I messaged my mods about it.
Because I was like really worried.
Um...
But sometimes...
Okay.
I'll let you in.
Okay guys.
We're gonna...
Oh my god.
You guys are gonna be like...
That's so tsundere.
Like...
Okay.
Look.
Um...
The last...
I think like the last like...
Two to three streams...
Um...
That I did.
Last two to three streams I did...
I like messaged my mods.
Like...
Uh...
One or two of my mods.
And I was like...
Was I too mean?
God!
That is like...
Oh my god.
Guys.
Was I...
Was I too mean to the dragoons?
Like do you think I was too mean to them?
I hope like...
I hope like the dragoons know that I was just joking around.
Like...
I was like...
Oh man.
I hope they know that I was just...
Uh...
That I was just like...
Joking around.
And I didn't really mean that.
Like...
I didn't...
They're like...
No, It's okay.
They like that.
I was like...
Are you guys sure?
I...
I don't know.
I feel like I was...
Like...
Sometimes.
You know?
It's like...
Um...
I feel like I would be like...
I felt like I went too far this time.
Are you guys...
Are you guys sure?
I was like...
I'm not...
I'm not too mean.
Hahaha...
Hahahaha...
So...
So, so...
The last like two to three streams, I actually felt like I hope I wasn't like going too far With like my jokes and stuff so I was like, oh my gosh I feel like I was like, I was like, I felt like I went too far Do you guys think I went too far?
Like I don't know.
I don't know if they actually thought that was funny or like if I was just if like I actually offended people
Oh my god, I don't remember what it was that like made me loop into that cuz like sometimes I go into this like Loop where I'll be like, oh no did I like go too far?
I was like, I'll be like looping at a lot over and over again because I'll be like, oh no did I?
Did I like did I?
Push too far there
I don't remember what it was that I don't remember exactly but like the next day I'll be fine I'll be fine the next day But like I was getting to that I'm not always but it was like a two to three street for like the last two to Three streams.
I was just like oh no was I did I go too far this time?
Oh yeah, it was definitely Definitely in Neopets where you know I was like be sick I was like, oh you got Neopox good
Okay now I remember it was the Neopets portion where I named what named the Neopet Dragoon I was like I threatened to pound you I Threatened to throw you into the pound and I was like, oh no Did I go too far with that?
I was like, oh no Now I remember I always like I always like forget about it the next day I always forget about it the next day, but it was definitely like something in the last two three That's why I was like oh no if I had these thoughts if I start having these thoughts I'm gonna like eat myself alive.
Like it's gonna eat myself alive.
So I was like, oh, maybe I'm just like tired Like I that's why like that's why I was like, okay.
I definitely mean Back to back rest days because if I start having these thoughts that means I'm like really tired like I'm like, I'm really tired to the point where I like I'm actually like overthinking it and like and happy in content creator the worst thing you can do is like overthinking and It was it was just like me overthinking it and like being like,
oh no if I like overthink this And I like second-guess myself, that's not good.
So I definitely needed the rest So that's why I'm taking the two back-to-back days And if a third day if needed if I'm still like in that like mindset after the second day, so But yes guys sometimes, you know sometimes Sometimes...
Okay,
look guys.
I might make you starve sometimes.
But like, it is with good intentions.
Look.
I just need you guys to know that it is with good intentions.
Chat.
Hats, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I cannot get over how cool your new skin suit is.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really glad.
I'm glad you guys like this new skin suit.
Like I said, when I've been planning the new skin suit and everything that was like...
I just could find it in like a couple of like you know, a couple of months ago in Avad, where I was like oh yeah, I just finalized the design and I'm so nervous, I'm so scared.
Like will they like it?
Because branding is everything.
Like...
And...
And like I'm just really happy that in the end, like everything came out like good.
And people actually... the reception of it was great and everything.
Like a lot of my worries are definitely like gone.
So I'm really happy about that.
Um...
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba Okay...
Noroko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much, but I hope I can bribe you to promise that you will rest as much as you need.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, yes.
That's why I am going to...
I am going to try and rest as much as I can.
And also catch up on some work in the next two to three days depending on...
Um... depending on...
Um...
How I feel after the second day.
Um... but it's nice.
I always like doing these Goodnight Dragoon streams because I can, you know, relax, unwind myself, uh...
Just like have like real talk with you guys and like...
Uh... you know, just enjoy each other's companies.
Um...
Kaz, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
We're being mushy anyway.
Today is my first year anniversary of discovering you!
Um... I don't even watch VTubers before that.
So thanks for the incredible times.
Off to another year.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it, Kaz.
Um... it is actually crazy.
I've... I remember like doing the panels.
Uh... doing some of the panels at...
Uh...
Uh... in the various conventions I attended the last couple of months.
And...
I think like two of them I had like Bark Knights showing up.
And it's actually really crazy to see sometimes.
Because like there was not a lot of Bark Knights.
Like...
I... there wasn't a lot of Bark Knights.
So...
It's really insane sometimes to like be able to like have some of the like...
Uh... like original Bark Knights coming in and being like, oh I...
I've watched you all the way since then.
Like I'm an OG Bark Knight.
And everything.
I don't know if you guys know this but... um...
Back then...
Uh... during like the Bark Knights time...
Um... I...
We would... I would like send like... uh... a lot of the Bark Knights like... um...
They... there was a collection.
I think it was like...
I'm trying to remember how many I printed out.
Um... I got main.
But like... there's one person...
Okay... each month...
I think like before like... uh...
You know when I first... uh...
Graduated... um...
I think like the last six or seven months... for...
For six to seven months... um...
Each month the top...
Was it top ten?
It was like top ten...
Um... Donator...
Or subscriber... when I used to do Twitch...
Uh... when I used to do Twitch streams... so it was easier to track this...
And there was not a lot of us... so it was really easy... easy to track this... but it was like...
I think it was like five...
Or ten... um...
Top ten...
I guess like... Donator...
Slash... gifted...
Uh... gifted subs...
Would get like... postcards...
Uh... with...
Postcards... uh...
Uh... being like the top supporter...
Of the month... and...
Uh... I remember I would... I'd do stuff like...
That... obviously I can't do that anymore...
Because there's a lot of us now...
But back then...
Um... to show my appreciation...
Um... because like...
Uh...
I don't know if you guys know this... but...
Um... during the Bark Nights time...
Um... even though I had...
Like...
Like 30... like 20 to 30...
Average viewership... um...
Obviously like... my average viewership...
Went up a lot because I did like...
Partner push... but it was because like... I did a lot of...
There was a lot of lurkers... so I did a lot of partner pushes...
Uh... because it took me like...
Like...
I got rejected like...
Three times... so...
So...
And you have to wait...
Like... I think like... two months...
Or something... to reapply again...
It was either... I think it was like one or two months...
I don't remember... it was so long ago...
Um... but yes...
I'm pretty sure there's like... somebody...
Uh... there's still fans... I know I have a lot of...
Bark Nights that are still here... that...
Still owns the last like...
Six to seven... like...
The seven month postcards of...
The whole collection of them...
Um... and everything... just to like...
Show my appreciation and stuff...
But it's always crazy to see...
That there's like a lot of fans that came from...
Years, years ago...
That are still supporting me to this day...
And I really appreciate it... and the new fans too...
Um... I really appreciate all the new fans...
And all the old fans...
And all like... um... fans who just started watching me...
And they're still watching me...
I really appreciate it... cause like... every...
Every one of you guys...
Um... do so much...
Even if it's just watching me...
Um... it's like... you guys support me a lot...
Uh... and you know... keep me relevant...
Hahahaha...
Because... as a content creator...
That... that's...
That helps a lot... you know...
Hahahaha...
That... that helps a lot... um...
Let's see...
Uh...
Where was I?
Simpson, thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Uh... my fellow goons...
And dookies...
Should I order the big cheese it Crunchwrap Supreme...
Or the regular Crunchwrap Supreme from Taco Bell?
It's free either way...
I don't know...
I've never had Taco Bell...
Hahahaha... I don't know...
Whichever one makes you use the bathroom less...
Because that's the only thing I know about Taco Bell...
Um... is that...
You... um...
Is that...
Is that something you eat...
Where you have to use the bathroom...
Um... so which... I guess like whichever one does it less...
Like...
Don't do it... it's gross...
It's fast food... like...
You know what you're getting when you're at fast food restaurants...
Like... like...
It's not like it's healthy for you...
Like...
You know what...
You know what you are if you're ordering...
Taco Bell...
Hahahaha...
You know what you sign up for...
Uhhh...
Oh my gosh...
Umm...
Let's see...
I'm looking at my list of stuff I wrote down...
Um... oh my gosh...
It was actually really funny...
Um...
Oh... right after like...
The Neopets stream...
Right after the Neopets stream...
There's like so many things that just popped in my head...
And I was like... Oh why didn't I talk about that...
Like... I was just like remembering like...
The history of Neopets...
And... um...
And everything...
Because I wasted so much of my life...
On that website...
And... um...
I was like remembering how... uh...
How there was like the underground...
That was funny... I was like talking about like the underground...
Black market for Neopets...
I mean to be fair... there's an underground black market...
For...
A lot of video games...
Um... there's like... I won't be surprised if there's one for like...
Runescape and World of Warcraft...
But... I know that...
Uh...
Wasted... well like...
I lost my main account...
Hahahaha...
So like... I feel like...
I feel like I could say that...
As somebody that's lost...
Your main account...
That got...
Cookie grabbed...
Hahahaha...
Um... oh for those who don't know about the...
Neopets black market...
Um... the Neopets...
Black market was basically...
Like any other video game black market...
Uh... similar to the Mercy...
Mercy skin black market...
The pink Mercy skin black market...
Um... at one point in time...
Um... there were pets...
Called the unconverted pets...
Uh... for those who are like...
What do you mean by that?
Um... well unconverted pets are...
Oh... sorry I need to play my lo-fi...
Music track again cause...
All the songs are done...
Uh... but basically...
In the...
Back then they did a thing...
Where in the past...
They would use original art...
Uh... they would use like...
Original art for each Neopet...
And because of that...
Uh... each Neopet had...
Each special Neopet had its own like...
Uh... unique pose...
Unique like...
Uh... unique cut... like unique pose...
Unique expressions and everything...
Um... unique artwork...
For basically almost every...
Uh... design and every like...
Pet... but then...
Um... later on...
Uh... when...
Uh... when you know it got owned by different companies...
When like the original creator...
Neopets sold the company...
Um... it went to a group of people...
Who were very...
Into...
Profits...
And into like... it got onto the...
Public stock market...
So people got really really into...
You know... try to make as much profit...
As they can off of Neopets...
And one of the things they did...
Was that they basically...
Made it so that...
Um... they changed the art style...
Of Neopets...
To one where every...
Um... every design of a Neopet...
Had a fixed...
Pose...
Um... it had a...
Fixed pose...
And a fixed like...
Um... standard... like a standard default expression...
Because...
They started selling cosmetics...
And called...
Uh... and they opened a thing called...
The Neomall...
And Neocash...
So Neocash was obtained...
By... with real money...
And... and back then...
You don't need to spend real money in Neopets...
It was just...
Neopoints...
And... uh... they...
Did that... so that they could start...
Um... monetizing...
They can start monetizing...
Uh... uh... cosmetics and stuff...
Where you can put like backgrounds...
Buy backgrounds... buy outfits... and everything...
Um... there was much more...
Customization to it...
But... it ended up...
Making the pets really ugly...
Hahahaha...
So... um...
Because of that... they only...
It only hit...
The 99%...
Of Neopets...
Users...
So...
Because of that...
The 1% of pets...
Did not get...
Converted...
Into that... into the...
Newer art style...
So... the 1%...
Of like... Neopets...
There were like 1%... like...
Some owners... some Neopet owners...
Will have all their pets converted...
Or maybe it was like all pets... but one...
Like... like... cause you can only own 4...
So like only one of your pet...
Was not converted into that art style...
So... because of that...
That started...
The underground...
The underground black market...
Of people selling...
Neopets... for...
Thousands of dollars...
And obviously... the longer the years pass...
Um...
The longer the years...
Passed...
The rarer it got...
Because sometimes... you know...
People who own the pet...
Um... they...
Their account will get frozen...
So like that pet was gone forever...
You know...
Like...
It was gone forever...
So... um...
So like... you know... the really rare pet...
Never to be seen again...
So some of you guys are like...
Oh... it can't be that much of a big difference...
Okay... I'm gonna like... let me show you guys...
Like the big differences...
Between... alright...
The... um...
Um... the Neopet veteran players...
Give me an example of like...
A really beautiful pet...
By...
The conversion...
Hahaha...
Which...
Give me an example... like the best example...
You can think of... that was...
Oh... the Halloween...
Hahaha...
Okay... alright... let's see...
I like how everyone's like... Shoryu...
Hahaha... I don't even remember...
I wasn't a Shoryu... uh... owner...
I didn't care about Shoryus...
As much as like others...
Hahaha...
The Shoryu wasn't that bad...
I don't think...
I don't think it was as bad as like the others...
Hahaha...
Um... oh my god... everyone...
Is like Shoryu... I think it...
I think it wasn't that bad...
It wasn't as bad...
Hahaha...
Let's see... um...
It was less dynamic...
Okay... that's true... cause they're all just standing there...
In the past they would just like...
They would actually fly... but then they like...
Grounded them so they would just stand there...
Um...
Shoryu...
Hahaha...
It lost all their dynamic poses... yes I agree with that...
Alright... let's see...
Okay... but like a specific one...
A specific style...
A specific like... uh...
Okay... I'll give you guys this one...
Okay... I'll show you guys like what I mean...
Um... oh the fairy...
Do you guys remember the fairy Zweetok?
The fairy Zweetok was so pretty...
Um... alright... I'll show this fairy Zweetok...
Okay... so this is like...
One of the pets...
Uh... where's the converted one though?
Okay... the fairy...
Zweetok... oh shit... oops...
Welcome back dad...
Hahaha...
Alright... so...
Uh...
Buh buh buh buh buh...
Alright... this is a good example...
Like...
Uh... let's see...
Let me clip this...
Alright... give me a sec...
Dad... we need to make sure you don't keep showing up all of a sudden...
So I'm gonna disappear for a sec...
Dad!
Wait!
Hahaha... Dad...
You can't keep...
You can't keep showing up...
Okay dad... okay...
Alright... sorry...
Um... I closed the door so...
So he wouldn't keep showing up...
Oh...
Hahaha...
Don't put him in the bath...
Alright...
Let me show you guys...
What I mean when I say they like...
Basically...
Changed a lot...
So... oh there's also this one too...
I guess like... I'll use my mods example too...
Cause they're very passionate about the Halloween Lupe...
Uh...
Because they're a furry...
Hahaha...
Anyway...
So...
So like... this is what...
The... I did not...
I did not say anything...
Hahaha...
Okay...
So like... um...
Alright... let me make sure I grab this picture...
Real fast... I'm grabbing the picture now guys...
Um...
Uh...
Alright... let's see...
So they're really passionate specifically...
About the Halloween Lupe...
Because this is what they...
Used to look like...
And... uh...
Yeah... like... I don't know...
How else to explain it... but...
Hahaha... like... literally...
All I can say is...
Yeah... Hahaha...
Hahaha...
I can't explain it in any other way...
Like when you see it, you'll be like...
Oh yeah... Hahaha...
That's why they're sad that...
Hahaha...
So this is what they looked like before...
Like this would be unconverted...
And... um...
The unconverted Halloween...
Uh... Lupe design...
And then... so... and then after that...
They converted it...
And... this is what they looked like...
After that... so...
Um... so you know...
You can tell why... you can tell why...
You know... they... they...
Haha... people were really mad...
About this... Hahaha...
Hahaha...
Because... especially because... like...
Um...
A lot of them...
A lot of them... they stopped...
What's the word?
They... it's like... when they used to be...
Like... when they used to be... like... you know...
On... on...
You know... two feet...
They regressed back into being...
Like four feet... so...
So people got really mad...
About it... and...
One of the things... one of the designs...
That got hit the most is...
The royal paintbrush... because like...
It made the royal pets look...
Really ugly... in general...
Because people were like...
What the fuck... like...
Like...
Who put this Halloween costume on them?
So... I'll give you guys an example...
So this... used to be called...
The royal...
Um... the royal...
Uh... brush...
The royal boy brush... so if you have a boy...
Boy Lupe... it would look like this...
So this is...
Um... this is what they would look like...
And then... after...
After the conversion...
They would look like...
Uh...
This...
Oh... where's the picture?
Wait... where did it go?
It just...
It just disappeared...
Okay... sorry...
Where did it go?
Oh my god... where did it go?
Okay... transform... reset transformation...
Wait... where the fuck did it go?
I like... saved it and it disappeared...
Oh my god...
Oh there it is...
Okay... this is what it looked like...
Sorry...
So... you know... people...
People got really mad...
Oh god... really?
It converted...
Oh there was an invisible brush too...
There was...
Oh... JL... thank you for the super chat...
Thank you for the akasupa... thank you...
Okay... yeah... I saw there...
The furry bros on this bad conversion...
Of Lupe...
They just...
You know... it's like they...
They got a dog...
And they gave it a fake beard and everything...
Um...
So...
So that's why people got...
Incredibly mad about this...
Because you know... they're like...
I didn't spend millions of neopoins...
Just to have my...
Fucking...
Majestic...
Royal... royalty dog...
An actual dog...
I mean...
We have one...
Yes...
Of course... I'll show you the furry...
The furry guys...
Got hit the hardest...
Um... the furry...
Okay... so you know how I said the...
The grey pets...
Uh... the grey pets were...
Like... people really loved...
The grey pets...
Because before then...
The unconverted...
Grey pets... Oh yes...
Also like all the lupis started making suggestive eyes...
Which made some people uncomfortable...
Um... anyway... because you know...
They're like... literally dogs...
But...
One of the biggest nerfs...
Was that the grey pets...
The reason why grey pets were like...
Really really valuable...
Was because they were one of the most...
Expressive...
Uh... one of the most expressive...
Uh... designs...
Out there... so... I'll give you guys an example...
These... the brush...
Used to be very very expensive...
Because they were like one of the most...
You know... they're depressed...
But like people really thought it was really cute...
Uh... so... but they were like one of the most...
Expressive...
Uh... designs out there...
So like this is what...
This side bunny would look like before...
And then... and then...
The conversion happened... the great conversion happened...
And...
This is what they...
Went into...
Like...
Now he's just grey...
Like he's not actually sad...
Like... I can't feel...
The depression anymore...
Like...
So people got really mad about it...
Cause they're like...
Why isn't my pet...
As depressed as it was before...
So people got like...
People...
People got really mad...
About that...
And...
Here's like... here's another one...
Like... um...
Oh my gosh... I'm trying to find one that was like...
Mega changed... like the...
The one... the... um...
Biggest examples...
Of it...
Oh here's one... okay here's one of them...
This is like... okay here's another one...
Um... cause like they all...
During the great conversion...
They all basically... it's like the same pose...
It's just... all they change...
Was like the colors...
So people got really mad about it...
So here's another one...
This is a very sad horse...
Uh... very sad like...
Unicorn Pegasus...
Um...
And they're called a...
Uni...
That's like... and then this is what happened...
During the great... like this is...
You can tell like... they're really sad...
They're very very sad...
Um...
And then...
Um... this is what they did...
Now...
They're just you know... they got something in their eye...
Like...
Like you can feel the depression...
Here... um...
Where... where you know... like...
The... the horse...
You know... hasn't really taken a shower...
In a couple of days...
Um... their hair is a mess...
And then this guy...
On the top during the great conversion...
Um...
You know... they just... they got...
Something in their eye...
Like they got something...
And...
Um...
That's why...
There was an underground...
There was an...
Underground black market...
For...
Mealpets...
And people were selling these guys...
Like especially these guys...
For like thousands of dollars...
In like real money...
Because they're like...
Because these guys were like super rare to get...
And they're like super expressive and everything...
Yeah... like the details were just all gone...
And stuff...
Oh my god...
Speaking of... like... it was actually crazy...
I was looking through like...
Um... I was looking through the new colors...
That they have in Mealpets...
Did you know there's like the elder...
You can like make your pets old now...
Which I was...
I was...
I was so surprised...
About...
Um... because like... I did not realize...
Like... what...
I don't know... I'm just...
I guess like the roleplay will go super hard...
But...
I'm like here thinking...
Why would I want to make my pet old...
Like...
There's...
There's like an old...
Okay... I need to show you guys...
Because I thought it was really funny...
When like... I thought...
It was so funny...
I didn't realize it was a real thing...
Um... but this is...
This is like one of their newest...
Brushes...
Which is like an old...
So you can make your pet fucking old...
Sorry... it's so funny...
I thought it was so funny...
I'm like... why?
Um... but yes...
You can turn your Mealpet...
Into like...
I guess your grandpa...
Oh wait... there's like...
Okay... let me see if there's...
Let me look through these...
I need to look through the...
I'm gonna look through these...
Oh my gosh... this one's funny...
There's like... this one...
I'm just... I don't know...
I don't know what to say...
Like... I... I... I don't know...
Oh yeah... and then...
Okay...
You can even like...
Take off their clothes...
Because like... I don't know...
And I don't know why... but like... you can also take off their clothes...
So like... this is like...
What one... this is them...
Clothes... but then like...
Because they're wearing glasses... right?
But then obviously you can take off their clothes...
But it was... it's only like...
The thing is... it's like only their...
Their... their face...
That's old... and that's it...
So here's like an example...
Like here's like what it looks like...
But it's only their face...
Like... I don't understand...
Like...
I... I... I guess...
Like... let me try like...
Maybe I'll take off clothes for the other ones...
Okay sorry... the context for this is really bad...
Um... but I just wanna know like...
What... what it would look like...
I... I guess...
Like... there's wrinkles on them...
Um...
But like... I don't really see...
Like...
What the difference really is...
Other than the face...
No!
Don't take off their clothes!
Oh!
There's like... okay there's one for like...
The female version of it too...
Wait let me show you guys the female version...
Don't worry...
I didn't take off... I didn't take off the clothes...
I just wanna show you guys the female version of it...
This is the female version of a Pateri...
Look!
There's Granny!
That's gonna be...
That's gonna be us one day...
That's gonna be me!
But there's like...
The elderly brush too...
Um...
Anyway...
The Neopets rabbit hole...
Goes really deep guys...
It really does...
I was rewatching the Neopets VOD too...
And like... I didn't even realize...
There's a memorial?
I was like... I was looking through the VOD...
And I realized they added like...
New things on the map...
And I was like... Wait there's a memorial...
Like I saw this...
I saw this... Why is there a war memorial?
Like...
Hahahaha...
Why?
Why is there a war memorial...
In my Neopets game?
Do you know what this...
Okay... Do you know what it looked like before?
This is what Neopets...
Looked like before...
That's why I was freaking out...
I was like... Who told them to civilize?
Like... Hahahaha...
They used to have no houses...
They lived in caves...
So I was like...
I was just like... Who taught them how to build a bridge?
Hahahaha...
What happened to my prehistoric lands?
What happened?
Anyway...
Like I said... Neopets actually...
In the story of Neopets...
They...
They actually...
They can actually...
Die...
So that's why there's a war memorial...
And then...
This is what it looked like before...
So I was just like... Oh my god...
They fucking...
They learned how to build infrastructure...
Who taught these cavemen...
How to build infrastructure?
Hahahaha...
Soon they're gonna evolve...
And learn how to drive cars...
They're not gonna be the priest...
What was the point of painting them in the pure historic era...
If they were just gonna evolve anyway...
Like...
There's a reason why...
I kept them in this era...
Hahahaha...
Oh...
Sorry...
Moving on...
Moving on from Neopets...
I wanna talk about something else...
I never told you guys about this...
But like...
I actually really like Monster High...
For those who are like...
What the fuck is Monster High?
I don't like the dolls...
I don't give a fuck about the dolls...
I just really like the show...
And the lore...
I don't know if I've ever confessed that before...
But like...
I actually... unironically...
Watched Monster High show...
The Monster High show...
Not the newest one...
The newest one sucks...
And the movies... The movies suck...
But I used to watch the old style...
The original OG...
Monster High style...
And like... um... Ever After High...
I really liked Ever After High...
Ever After High...
Before they put it on...
Hiatus Forever...
Because it was not as popular as Monster High...
But I actually...
I actually used to watch Monster High...
And I really enjoyed it...
I don't care about the dolls...
Because like... I know that...
People... uh... what was it?
Mattel?
I feel like it's always Mattel...
Hahahaha...
Um...
But I...
I used to...
I used to watch the show a lot...
And also like the 3D animated movies...
Before they went with the newest style...
And um...
I really enjoyed it...
Oh it's Hasbro?
It was either Mattel or Hasbro...
I could never remember...
It... because like...
Because like you know...
It's always like ran by the two...
Doll companies...
And it's either Mattel or Hasbro...
But obviously like their main goal...
Is to make...
Merchandise...
Is to make shows...
To make shows...
To sell merch...
It doesn't matter how well the show...
Does...
As long as people buy the dolls...
That's all that matters...
The thing is...
I feel like Monster High...
Like the creators...
Of Monster High...
Mattel...
Or Monster High...
I feel like...
They didn't realize...
That the reason why a lot of people...
Bought Monster High dolls...
Was that they were really good...
For doll customization...
So people bought a lot of...
Monster High dolls...
Just to customize them...
Because they...
Want the dolls...
Because apparently...
Monster High dolls...
Were like the easiest...
To customize dolls with...
I don't remember the reason why...
But I have a guilty pleasure...
Of watching doll customization videos...
And um...
And like...
They always used Monster High dolls...
Because they always had the best...
I guess like the best mold...
For customization...
And...
I miss Monster High...
I love that show...
That was such a good show...
Also Ever After...
Oh my gosh...
I wish they didn't reboot it...
I don't know...
I really like the style...
Oh my god...
My Vtuber is a girl...
Hahahaha...
Anyway...
It was so...
It was so iconic...
Hahahaha...
No way...
Was I ever into Bratz...
I was never into dolls...
I was never into like...
My Oshis a woman...
Hahahaha...
Anyway...
Bro...
My Brotuber...
Hahahaha...
My Brotuber is a woman...
Anyway...
Real female...
Doki...
Hahahaha...
Dude... Bro...
Uh...
Fuck... What was I on?
What was I on before I got distracted there?
Oh yeah...
I wasn't into dolls...
I was not into like...
Dolls in general...
I honestly...
The closest to dolls that I liked...
Like you know...
Like actual dolls was Littlest Pet Shop...
Littlest Pet Shop that's you...
Wooo...
I used to have...
I used to buy a shitload of Littlest Pet Shop figures...
Like I had like the...
The big, giant, Littlest Pet Shop...
Um...
A grooming station...
Um... With like you know the pet shop...
Where like you can like...
Uh... Bathe the pets and everything...
And I would buy like specific...
Like I wouldn't even buy like sets...
I would also buy like specific...
Like pets as well...
I'll be like...
Oh that's a rare one... It says it's a rare one...
I want it...
And I would buy like a lot of the Littlest Pet Shop...
Um...
The Littlest Pet Shop...
Figures and everything...
I think that was like the closest to like figures...
Like not figures... Sorry...
The closest to like dolls I ever had...
I'm trying to remember if I had like other dolls...
But I don't think I did...
I just had like... I just really played with Littlest Pet Shop...
I played with Littlest Pet Shop...
Um... Or like video games...
Cause like... I was like...
Why the fuck would I play with dolls when I can play video games...
You know... Like...
That was my... That was my mindset...
As like... Like...
As a child... I was like... Why?
Hahaha...
I don't need to use...
My imagination...
If I had video games...
Like...
So...
I like never really had like...
Like toys...
I guess like I did have toys...
Like I... You know... Like interactive toys...
Like... Um...
I had interactive toys...
That was like...
Supposed to like help with like...
Electronics and stuff... Like there's like one that like...
The leapfrog thing where like...
It was a book that teaches reading...
And stuff... Um...
So you can like get a pen and then like...
Like go over words and stuff...
And it'll be like... This is how to learn to read...
And stuff like that... But like...
I don't think I ever like... I rarely ever...
Physically played with toys...
Um... It was mostly just like...
Video games like Game Boys...
DS...
Uh... Game Boy Advance...
Consoles like PlayStation 1...
Um... PlayStation 2...
Uh... No Xbox...
Cause I said my dad hated...
Um... Xboxes...
Um... He only bought... I told you guys...
He only bought Xbox once...
And it was for the 360...
For some exclusive shit... I don't remember what...
Exclusive was there for on the 360...
That made him buy an Xbox...
Oh!
Gears of War!
Um... Gears of War was...
Exclusive on the Xbox...
And then so it was like... On the Xbox 360...
So it was the only time...
He's ever owned an Xbox 360...
Speaking of Xbox...
The Xbox has the fucking worst naming convention...
I've ever seen...
For a console... Like...
The newest Xbox is called what?
The Xbox One S?
Like...
What... What does that mean?
It has...
It has such a fucking...
A fucking terrible naming convention...
Like... I... I...
Why?
Why is it... The newest one?
Is it like... Xbox...
I need to pull it up... I was like reading it...
And I was like... They released...
They released a new... New generation of Xbox...
And it's like... Xbox...
What... Like...
What was it?
S?
The series SXS one?
Okay... Xbox console...
Names...
Okay...
The Xbox series S... Okay...
Okay... I'll show you guys...
Why I think like...
The Xbox has one of the...
One of the...
The worst naming...
Worst fucking...
Series of names I've ever seen...
For anything...
The Xbox series...
For those who don't know...
This is like...
So...
There's the original Xbox...
The Xbox 360...
The Xbox 360 core...
The Xbox 360 elite...
The Xbox 360 arcade...
The Xbox 360 S...
Xbox 360 E...
Xbox One...
Xbox One Elite...
Xbox One S...
Xbox X... One X...
And then the Xbox One S...
All digital edition...
And then...
Xbox... I don't know what this is... What is this one?
What is the newest one?
So...
I never understand...
I never...
Xbox... The Xbox Series X...
Oh yes!
Sorry...
That's the Xbox Series X...
So...
Like... How?
I'm like... How do you keep...
Keep up with that?
Like...
How... How do you keep up with that?
How do you keep up with that?
At least like...
You know... PlayStation 1...
PlayStation 2...
PlayStation 3...
PlayStation 4...
And finally... PlayStation 5...
How the fuck am I supposed to remember...
Xbox Series 1 X?
Like... How?
Um...
At least like... At least Nintendo...
They had like...
The Wii U...
And then like... The Wii...
And then the Wii U...
You know... And then they scrapped the whole thing...
And was like... We're making a new console...
The Switch...
I hope they make a new Switch...
I hope... Because if they make a new Switch...
That means there's potentially...
They'll finally fix...
The...
They'll finally fix the...
The sticks...
The...
The controllers...
Will finally be fixed after that...
You know...
Sometimes...
The Joy-Cons...
They'll finally fix the Joy-Cons after...
The...
Um...
That's really all I want...
I want a new...
Nintendo Switch console...
Just for the sake of...
Finally... Joy-Cons being fixed...
Uh...
Out of context...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you... Thank you...
Doki Bird new skin name is...
X Doki Bird Doki Series D...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you... Thank you...
I really appreciate it... Thank you so much...
Um... It just reminded me of like...
Uh...
Of like...
The naming convention... Oh my god...
There was like the worst...
Movie franchise names...
There was like a movie franchise...
That had like...
The worst naming convention...
In regards to like...
The movie franchise...
But like... What was it?
There was like a movie franchise...
Is it Fast and Furious?
Yeah... Fast and Furious...
It's Fast and Furious...
I forgot...
Yeah...
Yeah... It's...
Fast and Furious...
It really reminded me of...
Fast and Furious movies...
I talked about this before... But if you guys did not know...
The Fast and Furious movies...
Have the worst...
Naming conventions...
For a movie I've ever seen...
And for those who have never seen it before...
Don't worry I got you guys...
So... Um... They basically...
Um...
They also like to fuck around...
With like different names...
And... Here you go...
So...
There's Fast and Furious...
The classic... Too Fast Too Furious...
The Fast and Furious Tokyo Drift...
The Fast and Furious...
Back Again...
Fast Five... Fast and Furious Six...
The Furious Seven...
Uh... The Fate of the Furious...
Where the fuck did Hobbs and Shaw...
Come from?
Um... That's...
I did not realize that existed...
Hahahaha...
The F9...
And finally...
The Fast X...
Hahahaha...
So... This is basically...
Like...
This is basically...
Like... The Xbox...
But like... Much more elaborate...
Uh...
Fast X...
Hahahaha...
Okay... And then I showed this before...
Fast and Furious Japanese...
Titles... Um...
The Japanese...
Titles was like...
Also very similar... Uh...
So... This is...
Uh... Let me show you guys...
What the Japanese...
Titles were... For them...
Um... I showed this before...
But I'll... I'll show it again...
Because... It's honestly one of my favorite things...
About... Hahahaha...
It's one of my...
It's one of my favorite things about the Fast and Furious...
Uh... Movie...
Franchise... So... This is like...
The Japanese...
Titles... Of it...
So... You can see they called it...
Wild Speed... Wild Speed X2...
Wild Speed X3... Wild Speed Max...
Wild Speed Mega Max...
Wild Speed Euro Mission...
Wild Speed Sky Mission...
Wild Speed Ice Break...
Wild Speed Super Combo...
So you know... They didn't care about the...
Hobbs and Shaw thing... They went...
Wild Speed Super Combo... Um...
And then Wild Speed Jet Break...
Hahaha...
So...
Um... At least they kept it...
Consistent... You know... The Wild Speed...
At least...
That was consistent... So this was like...
The titles of it...
In Japan... Um...
And... This just reminded...
Me of X... Like... Xbox...
Reminded me of this... Cause like... Fast and Furious...
Had like... I don't know...
They just throw some words in there...
And then... Hahaha...
They just... You know... Throw some words...
In there... Hahaha...
Um...
Uh...
Let's see...
Ah...
Uh... Dag... Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you... Thank you... I really appreciate it...
Thank you so much...
Oh... I saw somebody earlier... Asking about...
My opinion on the game... And...
Uh... Uh... They wanted me to...
Answer it... So... Influx... Thank you...
In the super chat... Influx... Thank you... Thank you...
Thank you... Hey Toki... Speaking of your dad...
You mentioned... He loved the Yakuza series...
But you found it too long... So I suggest...
Like a dragon... It's shorter...
But it touches on the previous game... So you can...
Get a feel for the series... Thank you... Thank you... Thank you...
Thank you... No matter what...
The reason why... I have not... I think I've talked about this before...
But like... Um... I don't touch the Yakuza series...
Because like...
Even though like... No matter what...
Their defi...
The Yakuza definition of like...
Short... Is like...
Really... Still really long...
Hahaha...
It... It...
It...
It... Like... It's like...
A shorter version of Yakuza...
But like... It's still...
Incredibly long...
Like... It's... It's...
Still a very very very long game...
And it's like... You have to dedicate like...
At least like... A month...
Like... Sandland took us a while...
But Sandland is actually known as...
Like... One in the...
Sandland is supposed to be like...
A short RPG...
Um... Action RPG...
But even then... Like... Sandland took us a long...
Time...
Hahaha...
Like... I think it took us like...
A month and a half to finish Sandland...
So... So...
That's why like... I try to not...
Um...
Try to play... Not...
Try to... Uh... Not touch games that...
Are like... Incredibly long...
Because I know like... My strengths...
And I'm definitely like...
Guys... I can't read guys...
Like... Hahaha...
Guys... Your Oshii is illiterate...
Guys... Hahaha...
Hahaha...
So like...
We'll both struggle...
Hahaha...
I swear... I feel like...
I feel like I'm making you guys more stupid too...
I feel like the longer you guys watch me...
Like... I feel like we both...
Are like... Feeding into each other's illiteracy...
Hahaha...
I'm making you... I'm also making you...
As illiterate as me...
The longer you watch me...
Hahaha...
Um...
But that's why I tend to like...
Avoid... Uh... JRPGs...
Because like... I know that...
It's not my strength... And there's like... A lot of other...
Streamers who are...
Much better at streaming...
JRPGs than me...
Hahaha...
That's okay... I don't... I'm here to make sure...
You turn off your brain when you watch me...
Um...
No... No... Thank you for the super chat... Thank you... Thank you...
Uh...
And visual novels... Oh my god...
You know like... What else...
Oh my god... So like...
I realized... Like...
I actually thought about it for a while...
But I was like... Oh my god...
I could potentially stream Corpse Party...
But then like...
I was re-watching...
Oh my gosh... I was re-watching Corpse Party...
A playthrough... Because like...
I don't... Corpse...
I used to like...
Corpse Party was like... Super interesting...
But then I re-watched it...
And I was like...
I was re-watching Corpse Party a little bit...
And I realized like...
Uh... It was a very long game...
Like...
It's a hee hee hee...
It's... I...
I was like... Oh my god... I forgot...
It's so slow...
It's so...
And the writing...
The writing is not as good as I remembered...
I feel like...
Maybe I was like... Young...
I was like...
Really young...
Cause like... Guys... Corpse Party...
Came out in 2008...
Chat... That's...
Guys... It is...
It is a very old game...
And I'm like thinking... I was like...
Oh my god... I must have been...
Like...
I was...
Definitely like... Way too young...
To watch this...
...
I was...
I was way too young to watch it...
And then I was re-watched...
I was like... Watching like...
Going through like... A vibe...
Of it... And then...
I was like...
16 years ago...
That...
That was 16 years ago...
They're like... A junior...
In high school...
That...
They...
They can... They can drive...
17...
They can...
The game can literally drive now...
The game can...
What?
Whoever said...
Whoever was like...
That's not that old...
Umm...
...
The flow of time...
Is cruel...
Anyway...
Anyway... Umm...
By the way... Don't watch the anime...
For a course party...
I watched the anime for a course party...
It is...
It's really bad...
It's...
I don't remember...
I don't remember much about it...
I just remember it was very bad...
So...
And then I tried to watch the sequels...
The play game...
Like... How many games...
Has course party been?
Umm...
How many... Okay... There's...
Course party... There's...
What the fuck...
How many games have they made?
They made Batman... Oh no...
Holy shit...
That's a lot of course party...
What?
Course party... Course party...
New chapter... Course party...
Blood covered... Course party...
Blood covered... Repeated... Fear...
Course party... Book of Shadows...
Course party... Sweet Sachiko's...
Hysteric birthday bash...
Course party... Two dead patients...
Course party... Blood...
Drive... Course party... Two dead patients...
Nexus...
Course party... Two darkest... What are these...
When did they make...
All of these...
Course party...
What the fuck... I didn't even realize...
There was that many...
Course party...
That's a lot more than I...
Thought there was...
All I remember was the original...
Course party... I heard like...
Umm...
I tried to watch a play through...
Of the PSP game...
That somebody... When was it?
It was a course party...
No... It was like... Was it Book of Shadows?
I tried to watch one of the newest ones...
Umm... Oh yeah the playstation...
Was it Blood Drive?
It's not as good... It's...
It's like... I think cause...
Oh yeah they went with like a 3D model...
I think it's always whenever they go like with 3D...
It just starts being not as good...
Like...
Hahahaha...
But...
Oh my god...
It's actually...
Uhh... Yeah the chibi one...
Where they use like... It's just cause they use...
Chibi models... And like it always...
Feels weird when they like...
When... It's just like...
Cause it's supposed to be like this...
Horror game... And then...
They use like... Like...
Like... Umm...
What's that style called?
The original course party?
What was the style called?
The... Uhh... Yeah...
It just starts being scary...
In the chibi style...
Uhh... These corpses party more than I do!
Hahahaha...
Yeah the RPG maker...
Yeah... Like the RPG maker...
Has like...
A charm in it...
Where like... Umm...
Where... You know...
It has such a charm in it for the horror genre...
That when they started...
When they did the chibi style to it...
It just like lessens the horror...
But also if you guys rewatch...
Courts party...
Umm... The writing...
You realize there's like...
The writing for the game...
Was definitely filled with... Uhh...
Was not as great as...
Hahahaha...
I... I think...
I... It was like...
The...
It was just the part where like... You know...
The writing...
Yeah... I was... I was...
I remember rewatching it...
I was like... Wait... This was not as scary as I remembered...
Because there was like a scene...
It was a really fucked up scene...
In there... That...
What was it?
Like... It just has like...
Scary...
I was rewatching Courts party...
And like... Like... I was like...
There was a part in there... And I was like...
You know... Like one of the most scary... I'm gonna spoiler alert for it...
I was... I'll spo...
Like it was like... I'll spoiler alert for it...
Because it's like a game... It was just gore... It was very gory...
Like I think that was it...
The reason why is that...
Like when you're like... Especially when you're watching it...
When you're younger... Or like... Younger...
You're really surprised...
Because it was like...
The anime style... Like the anime cute style...
Especially like RPG Maker...
Cute style... And then they show like...
Gore... And then you know...
When you're younger... You're like... Oh my...
It's like... You know... Happy Tree Friends... You know... Like...
Like... It's like... Happy Tree Friends...
Where... When you're younger... You're like... Oh my god...
The gore... Stuff like that...
And...
And I remember it like...
Uh... There was that moment...
Where... Spoiler alert...
There was this really pivotal moment in there...
That was... That basically changed the...
Atmosphere of the game...
Where... Um... They bumped into two...
Child ghosts...
And then they like... Threw one of the...
The students...
Against the wall... And like she exploded...
Into guts... Stuff like that...
And then you know... It was like the first...
It was like the first... Like...
In your face... Um...
In your face moment... Where like...
Shit... This game is real... Like...
Yeah... Yeah... And like... You know...
That was like... That scene left an...
Impress... Like... That's literally like...
There's two scenes... That I...
Cause like... In Corpse Party...
I literally only remembered...
Two scenes... From there...
And... Cause it was like...
The most fucked up moments...
Like... Like... I was like...
They added that into the game...
One of them...
Was that one...
The second one...
Was where... I thought...
I was like... I...
I remember when I was a kid...
I was a kid... When that happened...
When I watched... When I watched that play through...
As a kid...
And I was like... What the fuck...
Why is it here?
Why was this...
And then... You know... As you got older...
You realize... Why...
They made that scene...
But it was when the little sister...
Kept being like... I need to use the bathroom...
Like...
And that scene...
Like... As a child...
Like...
I was like... Why?
And then... Yeah...
Those were...
The two scenes...
That like... Imprinted in my...
Mind... It was literally like...
The only scenes...
I remembered... Like...
Oh my god...
They were the only scenes...
I remembered...
Because they were left...
Like a fucking... They left like...
Oh my god...
Like...
And then... So then I like...
Rewatched... Course priority... Because I used to be like...
Obsessed with course priority... Back then...
Like a lot of people... Were super obsessed...
With course priority...
Every youtuber...
Um...
Streamed it... Every... Not streamed it...
Did a let's play of it... It was like...
What was it?
It was the purple...
I know... Was it the Oni?
Oh my gosh... What was it?
The...
That other RPG game...
It was the Ioni...
That... Course priority...
Um...
The witch one... The... Witches have...
The house... Was that one of them?
That's what it was called...
Uh...
Mad father...
What else?
I think that was like...
Uh...
Ib?
Oh yeah... There is Ib...
And then... Yeah... These were like...
The... I think like the top...
The five games... That were going around...
Like RPG maker games...
Were so popular back then...
And these were like the five ones that kept...
Everybody kept fucking...
Doing let's plays of...
So then like... I remember I was like...
I really... I like enjoyed the play throughs of that...
And like the lore and the story of all of that...
And then so like...
I remember I was like... And course party...
Was...
One of the only games...
That kept having sequels...
For some reason...
I don't know if you guys know this but...
Every other RPG maker game...
At that time...
Had like almost no sequels...
Or like...
Barely any sequels...
And course party...
Was literally the only game in...
One of the only games in that genre...
That had like...
A million sequels going in...
Like... So...
Everybody would always like...
Keep up to date with it...
So that's why like... I don't know...
They would have like anime adaptations...
Like several anime adaptations...
Might I add...
And...
Um...
Yeah... And then like... Looking back to it...
Uh... Looking back to it...
Like rewatching...
The gameplay of it...
I realized...
It wasn't as good as I remembered...
It was definitely not as good as I remembered...
I'm sorry...
Like it was definitely like...
The scare gore factor...
What the other games lacked...
Was the gore part...
Of course party...
And like the shock factor of it...
And... But the other games...
Did not have that... That's why people were like...
Oh my god...
...
Um... Yeah I feel like...
You had to be there at that time...
...
And it's like...
Similar for...
Uh... Yeah it was just... It was very memorable...
For the time it was released...
Because no other RPG maker...
That was popular...
At that time...
Like that was super popular...
Had the gore...
That course party had...
...
So...
Nowadays...
Um... Oh my BGM stopped... Sorry...
There's a lot of those now...
There's definitely a lot of those...
...
Um...
Yeah...
It was...
Just like a memories moment...
There...
...
What was I...
What else do I want to talk about today...
Um...
That was nice though...
It's nice like going through like...
Memory lane...
And just like rethinking back about like...
The type of games that were like super popular...
Like 10 years...
Not 10 years but like...
Uh...
...
More than 10 years...
By the way...
...
Uh...
The thing is...
There's like...
It's very rare to find good RPG maker games...
Uh...
Good RPG maker games...
Nowadays...
I feel like...
Um...
It's just...
Because like...
There's always like...
Ads and trends when it comes to certain video games...
Uh...
And RPG Maker, you know, you had to be there at around 2010 to like be there for the RPG Maker boom.
Where like there was a lot of RPG Maker games that had really really good story and really...
The art might not be like as good back then too.
Like the only reason the art improved was that it gets like re-releases or HD remakes.
But it was like a bunch of like small town small-time artists like drawing it for their own free time and stuff.
But it was like an interesting time back then.
I think now the current fad right now is...
Someone... oh yeah by the way, I saw that somebody asked me if I was gonna be at Evo.
I cannot confirm or deny it.
That's...
That's all I'll say.
Anyway, I think like...
I think like...
The current gaming fad right now, the gaming trend right now is...
I'm trying to like think of like what new games... I honestly think...
Currently the newest gaming trend is fighting games.
Due to like...
A lot of stuff.
Oh, yeah, by the way, I thought it was so funny because it popped because like, you know, I follow like...
From Sajam Slam.
I follow like a lot of people from Sajam Slam on Twitter.
So like I saw the one about...
That video about how some like...
Pro player for one of like the fighting game tournament is...
Through a chat, he's like...
He's like, I'm gonna throw a chair and like destroy a lighting equipment that was worth $4,000 or something.
So like they subtracted their earnings and now he has a negative earning.
I thought that was so funny.
So this guy won a fighting game tournament, but like you wouldn't...
He won barely any money.
He won barely any money from that fighting game tournament.
And he celebrated by throwing a chair behind him.
And like destroying this lighting equipment that was worth like...
I don't know, like...
A lot of money.
So now on his like...
Liquipedia on his like pro player...
Pro player...
Uh...
Tournament earnings sheet.
He has negative earnings.
Yes, he was the first winner ever.
In a...
In like as a pro player to have a negative $2,000.
Uh...
Overall earnings.
Wait...
Mon, do you have a...
Do you have a video clip of it?
Uh...
I saw it on Twitter.
It was...
I was like...
What the fuck?
He actually...
And like...
And then somebody was like...
That was like not even a good winner.
Like...
Yeah, like people were saying like...
He didn't like...
The...
The matchup wasn't even like that great.
Like...
Um...
Alright, let's see.
He didn't fully commit to the pop-up.
Basically he won the dead.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna see if I can...
Let me see if I can find the video.
I just love the Twitter comments of people like roasting in there like...
It wasn't even like...
That good of a pop-off though.
I was just like...
It was so...
Which I thought was the funniest part.
Let's see if they update it.
Oh, they didn't.
Okay, I want to see if they update it.
Oh, they deleted...
Oh, they deleted his Wikipedia.
That's sad.
Wait, that's actually sad.
Why did they...
Wait...
They deleted his Liquipedia.
Wait, did they actually?
He used to have it.
He literally had a Liquipedia.
I saw it.
I saw it too.
And it's like...
It's gone.
Oh my God.
They actually deleted it.
That's so funny.
Oh yeah.
Because the price...
Okay, this is why.
Okay.
All right.
So I'm going to show you guys...
Okay, wait.
Is it JPEG?
God damn it.
Why is it always a web?
All right.
I'll show you guys the picture and then I'll show you guys the clip.
Well, I'll link you guys the clip and not show you guys the clip.
Let's see.
Where is it on Twitter?
Where is it?
Oh, here you go.
Where the fuck is the pop-off?
Oh, there it is.
I want to see the pop-off clip.
Oh, sorry.
Not the pop-off.
The fucking...
By the way, the prize money was literally $500.
So people were like...
They were like, this was not worth it.
There we go.
This is the...
This was the video clip.
And like this was the...
Let me grab the screenshot.
Oh, there it is.
This is a screenshot of how much money he lost.
So basically, like it was a $3,000 light and he literally just won $565.
So he actually...
He...
No, but the reason why I said just $500 is because he literally broke a lighting equipment that's $3,000.
Like...
Oh, my God.
That's why...
That's why people were like...
People were like, what the fuck?
I wish I saw...
I wish like...
I saw the tweet about like...
I wish...
Oh, my gosh.
I wish somebody has that...
Where is that tweet?
It was so funny.
I saw...
It was...
I saw the Liquipedia entry too.
And they literally gave him like negative...
Like he literally wrote negative...
And it got deleted.
It got deleted!
They actually deleted his Liquipedia!
That's actually a cool name!
They deleted their Liquipedia!
Also, the reason why...
It's sort of easy to tell...
What is the current gaming trend.
You just see what Riot's doing.
So, they're currently working.
The thing is...
Riot is really good at figuring out what is the newest gaming trend.
And what to capitalize on.
What to develop.
I don't know if you guys saw this.
They cancelled a platform fighter.
But they're releasing a new fighting game.
They released a new fighting game.
To...
To capitalize on the fighting game genre.
So...
What is it?
The 2x KO?
I just think fighting games right now is currently the most popular gaming trend at the moment.
Because there's always gaming trend.
A couple of years ago, it was Battle Royale.
Now we're dying.
And now it's fighting games right now.
Especially competitive wise.
I feel like competitive wise...
Also, I'm pretty sure...
Riot is going into the fighting game genre.
So they can capitalize on fighting game tournaments as well.
Because like eSports.
Because they...
What Riot is really really good at...
Is making games for competitive eSports.
And I feel like...
I'm pretty sure they went for it.
They went for the new fighting game.
They went for fighting game because they want to get in on the EVO action.
As well as other tournaments that they can host themselves as well.
Umm...
Yeah, they're pretty...
Yeah, they're really good at...
Uhh...
They're really really good at...
At running like eSports events and stuff in general.
So I'm not surprised about that.
They really gotta figure out what games have like good eSports potential.
Umm...
Yeah.
I just think like that's the current trend when it comes to gaming.
Umm...
FPS is gonna die out.
Like...
Uhh...
Like RTS.
We're gonna die...
The FPS is gonna die out soon just like RTS.
Uhh...
Say it ain't so...
We're gonna be just like them.
RTS has new games?
Like what?
Name me...
Name me one right now that has...
Like...
That has like an actual player base.
That's not less than like...
That's not less than like 5000 players.
Hahaha...
Umm...
What else was I gonna say?
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh...
Uhh...
There's an upcoming RTS.
It's just gonna die out in like a month and you know it.
You know it.
Hahaha...
Umm...
Like I said...
Whoever said Stellaris, that's not an RTS.
Someone's very passionate about Stellaris.
Umm...
Oh my gosh there's something on mine.
But I forgot.
God damn it.
You know when you have like a thought in your mind and you just forgot.
Umm...
Oh my god what was it?
Ahhh...
Nooo...
I don't remember.
Hahaha...
I don't...
Nooo...
I don't remember.
Oh!
I saw like...
What is it called?
I wrote it down in my calendar.
But they're open up...
Opening up a...
Uhh...
There's a new game.
Early Access is coming out.
Concord!
Yeah!
Uhh... I saw like people were playing Concord...
This week.
Uhh...
Because it was in Early Access.
It's like...
The newest...
Call of Duty...
Slash...
Uhh...
It's like basically Call of Duty with different heroes.
And...
Umm...
I was like thinking about it.
We all know it's gonna die in a week.
But like...
Hahaha...
We...
We all...
Yeah...
We all know it's gonna die in like a week or so.
So...
But...
I'm just like wondering if I should try it out.
Umm...
I'm gonna play...
What is it?
I'm gonna play Marvel Rivals though.
Umm...
I asked the dev team to get the...
Uhh...
To get a code for Marvel Rivals.
So...
We're gonna...
I think Beta...
Beta is opening next week?
Yeah.
Beta...
Uhh...
The next Beta test is opening next week.
So...
I think I'm just gonna...
Because I was like debating if I should try Concord.
But I'm like...
Oh my god.
That game...
I'm sorry.
But that game looks so boring.
I'm just gonna...
Concord...
Concord looks so fucking boring.
Like...
I can't...
I was watching it and I'm just like...
It's just...
It's just Call of...
It's literally like...
They put...
They try to be like...
They try to be like it's a hero shooter.
But like...
Umm...
But they make it Call of Duty style.
So it's barely like a team shooter.
It feels more so of just like...
Umm...
It feels more so of just...
Call of Duty with heroes.
Yeah.
It's basically Call of Duty with heroes.
But it looks worse than Call of Duty.
So like...
I don't know.
I was watching a bit of...
I was watching Shroud play it.
Was it Shroud?
No.
I was watching...
I was watching Lyric play it.
Uh...
Cause Lyric was literally like the most...
Pop...
Like...
You know like when you...
Most...
The biggest streamer...
The biggest streamer that was playing it at that time.
So...
Yeah.
It looked...
Oh yeah.
It looked like Destiny 2 PvP.
Yeah.
I agree.
It looked like Destiny 2 PvP.
So I was just watching it and I'm just like...
I don't know.
It doesn't seem like it had anything new to the formula.
So I was...
It was just...
It was just like...
Space Call of Duty I guess.
Like...
But then...
Space Call of Duty is basically Destiny PvP.
So...
Like...
How could they improve on that when Destiny already has it for free?
So...
So most likely...
Most likely I'll just be playing Marvel Rivals next week.
I might...
I might play some Marvel Rivals next week.
I'm thinking of like...
Um...
I don't know.
Maybe I'll...
I'll try...
Um...
Uh...
Play more rank on it too.
Maybe.
But I'm not sure though.
I feel like...
We'll see.
We'll see how I feel.
Anyway!
I just realized it's been two hours.
Oh my god!
I've been talking for...
I've been yapping for two hours!
Oh!
Oh my god.
We had like...
This week I felt like I streamed a lot for this week.
Not gonna lie.
Um...
I streamed a lot this week.
So maybe that's why I feel like more tired in general.
But it was...
It's been a great time.
Just talking to you guys.
Just hanging out.
And having conversations with you guys.
Uh...
Um...
And...
Honestly...
Um...
Wait I...
Oh yeah!
I didn't purposely avoid the monster question guys.
I actually forgot.
I...
Um...
What was the original question?
Let me look back at it.
Just so I can answer.
Um...
I think...
Correctly.
Alright.
Where is it?
Um...
Next C!
Someone says...
Are you...
She said...
Are you saying...
You aren't into any monsters?
All I'm saying...
Is that...
Fuck.
Okay.
That's it.
I'm done.
That's...
That's it.
Anyway, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!